all three-day heatwave sounds lovely
doesn't it for most of us at least
temperatures should reach more than 30
celsius
that means a busy weekend on britain's
beaches and with
beaches with a water comes some danger
let's talk to ross mcleod from the royal
national lifeboat institute who's there
in poole bay
endorsement for us this morning it's
good to see you look i mean i i know the
rnli are not killjoys
in any way shape or form but you've you
know we need to understand the dangers
of beaches and dangers of the water
don't we
yeah absolutely good good morning
everyone and yeah we're down here today
in paul bay a beautiful day as you can
see and
everyone's had a really tough few months
um and it's no surprise that with jan
elia and our colleagues at the coast
guard are expecting it to be
one of the busiest summers on record and
with this good weather no doubt many
thousands of people will flock to the
coast and who can blame them
and so what we're really calling for
people to do is just to make sure have a
little bit of thought around
what potentially could go wrong
obviously we want everyone to have a
fantastic time at the coast
make some amazing memories and go home
safe at the end of the day so there's
just a few
things that you can do to make sure you
keep yourself and your family safe and
also
know what to do should the worst happen
okay so so what are some of these things
because i know the rnli has run
a campaign for a few years now just
talking about
respecting the water
exactly it is around just having a
healthy respect for the water and
start breaking that down the first thing
you can do is try and go to a supervised
place so especially if you're heading to
the coast
try and find a life-guarded beach and
the rnli runs around 245 beaches across
the uk so
there's there's beaches all over the
country plenty to choose from and when
you're there at these beaches we'd
encourage you to swim between the red
and yellow flags and that way you know
you've got a trained professional on
hand and
these guys and girls did a brilliant job
every year and last year
we know they saved around 110 lives so
if you are in these locations if
something does go wrong
you've got help close at hand and also
if you're going to any beach whether
it's lifeguarded or not if you find
yourself in difficulty in the water
remember the technique float to live and
this is just simply rest and relaxing in
the water extending your arms and legs
trying to float a bit like a starfish
put a bit of treading water if you need
to but the main thing is not to panic
whether you're getting swept out in a
rip current or you're falling in
unexpectedly
the worst thing you can do is panic so
just chill out in the water
uh wait for help to arrive or gather
your thoughts and your breath
um and call for help yourself and the
final one if you see anybody else in
trouble
is to remember to call 999 and ask for
the coast guard and that way
again we can get emergency services to
you no doubt it's going to be a busy
weekend
for everyone across the blue light
community but we really want to make
sure people put those calls in early
and so we can get to you and help and
try and resist the urge to go in the
water yourself because unfortunately
every year we see too many tragic
examples of the havago heroes that
unfortunately lose their lives as well
so make that call early um if you want
to try and help
find something that floats like a rescue
ring or a throw line or even an
inflatable football throw that into the
water
encourage them to calm down encourage
them to try and float but please don't
cut yourself
in danger as well i mean the the weather
might be gloriously hot this weekend but
we
that doesn't necessarily mean the water
is going to be going to be particularly
warm does it
no i mean we're expecting 25 to 30
degree air temperature but the water is
unlikely to reach above
13 or 14 degrees in most places and
probably a lot colder in land
and this can trigger something called
cold water shock if you jump in and it's
a
physiological reaction when your skin
temperature changes rapidly
we've done a lot of work with this with
professor tipton at the university of
portsmouth
and if you even if you're a good swimmer
if you jump into cold water this can
cause a spike in your heart rate it can
lose you cause you to lose control of
your breathing
and even in strong swimmers this can be
really dangerous quite quickly so we'd
encourage you to
enter the water slowly um if you're in
any doubt if you're not in the water
often
there's no shame in wearing a wetsuit
and this will also help keep you afloat
as well so
just take it easy acclimatise to the
water have a great and fantastic time
this this weekend but
just have half an eye on safety and make
sure you know what to do in an emergency
ross i hope you have a very quiet
weekend
fingers crossed thanks for talking to us
thank you